we're in the first week of April 2017 so
it's time for another monthly update
video I'll talk about what went on in
March turns out a lot and what we've got
coming up in April also a lot I'm also
very excited about the three big things
for this month so let's launch right
into those big thing number one we now
have available in the reason I owe
Academy a two-course series on
aristotle's Nick and McCain ethics this
is something I've been working on for
quite some time it's really a wonderful
set of resources to help learners make
their way through that but I'll talk
more about that in the April section
second thing also Aristotle related
later on this month we have a free
webinar and to online intensive seminars
coming up on the topic of Aristotle
friendship and relationships links to
that is also below in the video
description so you want to check that
out third big thing is not Aristotle
related instead it's connected with
Hagel so this month we're going to have
another Hagel party why a Hagel party
well because in the half hour Hagel
project we've actually finished the
reason section well or will I will
finish stuff about midway through the
month and are moving into the next
massive section of the work spirit
phenomenology of spirit is named after
that so those are the three big things
let's talk now about what went on during
march on a personal note what I'm going
to say is that i had thought march would
be my month to actually get caught up
because it's got 31 days so it feels
like you're getting a bonus after the
very short februari month but it didn't
turn out quite like that in part because
i got a lot of new work which is great
and in part because i also have been
working out which tires me out
physically and my my kids came to visit
for their spring break which i'm really
happy to have but means that I get a
little bit less work done
during during that time I cut back to
about four hours a day and some days I
didn't even do any work believe you're
not other than you know housework and
and tending to the to the kids but that
was really great so what went on during
the month of March we had a talk during
the series on philosophy and speculative
fiction on douglas adams Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy galaxy really great
you know some some excellent discussion
and attendance and there's been some
great comments on the video for that we
did our normal half hour hagel sessions
one you know for the public and one just
for Patrian subscribers we also began
the new webinar and online seminar
series with a webinar and two online
seminars on Aristotle's views on virtues
and vices and that went really well the
participants were very happy with it so
I'm really glad to kick it off in that
sort of way with you know a high note
and then towards the end of the month we
have three other events two of them were
associated with Women's History Month
one was a lecture on Mary Wollstonecraft
commissioned by the Brookfield public
library another began a new quarterly
series on women you should read this
year we're looking at philosophers will
probably actually continue looking at
philosophers for quite a while and we
talked about Princess Elizabeth of
Bohemia links to those videos are below
in the video description and we had our
Milwaukee MKE stoic fellowship meeting
again very well attended a lot of great
discussion that we had going on that
group is starting to gel I'm very happy
about that another thing that went on
during March is I had an interview with
Clifford sergeant who had started a new
podcast on the three books that have
changed your life so he asked me to be
the first guest on the podcast I was
very happy to do that because I really
like his work and so we did a
collaboration you can see it on his
channel i'll put a link to it below as
it turned out the three books that after
i gave a lot of thought to or Plato's
Republic Aristotle's
McCain epics and epic fetuses discourses
not a big surprise probably for for all
of you out there but it turned out to be
a big surprise for me after I thought it
through I did a good bit of video work i
did my six half flower Hagel videos for
the month getting us almost to the end
of the reason section I also shot a
number of videos on aristotle's
categories there's some new core concept
videos and I'm very happy about that I
did shoot another personal video this
one about having three fathers if you're
wondering what that means well take a
look at the video which I'll link to
below and we had videos for each of the
events that went on so one for Douglas
Adams one for Mary Wollstonecraft one
for Elizabeth of Bohemia I also started
teaching an online class for Maris
College an adjunct for them and
occasionally teach but just online and
so started a new world views and values
section which I had to redesign a little
bit because they've compressed it now
from 10 weeks to eight weeks so you know
there's a little bit of design work
involved I picked up some some new
tutoring clients some new philosophical
counseling clients did some more of both
of those and continued some of the
academic coaching and leadership
coaching that I've been doing I also did
a lot of course building culminating in
that Aristotle nikka McKay and ethics
online course a good bit of work for the
Institute of priority thinking
developing curriculum for them in their
educating the emotions series and a lot
of work on stoicism today as we gear up
for stoic on stoic week and a lot of
others don't created things there's a
good bit of work that has to be done for
the blog and that's quite rewarding I
didn't get quite so much writing done as
I have done in previous month's a little
bit of blogging not not too much I focus
more on academic writing because I have
a conference coming up that I'm working
on a paper for so I did a good bit of
work on
that but there's still more work to be
done this month so let's talk about
April now and I have a number of events
coming up I'm going to just sort of
rattle them off you'll see the dates and
time scrolling below and if you're if
you're in the area you're welcome to
come to any of them some of them are
online so you're also welcome to come to
any of those events as well so we're
starting on Thursday the 13th at seven
p.m. at the brookfield public library we
continue the philosophy and speculative
fiction series with a session on and
mcCaffery's first three books in the
dragonriders of Pern series first three
because it's a massive series that her
son has also continued I found this out
when I went to the library to check it
out so that'll be a fun discussion the
usual crowd i'm sure we'll be there but
you know we're always happy to see
newcomers as well if you're in the area
Wednesday April nineteenth at 5pm this
is central time because this is an
online event we have the half-hour Hagel
QA public discussion so if you've got
any Hagel related questions or you just
want to talk about Hagel and German
idealism pop on in we hold it in our
reason I oh free conference call meeting
space on from thursday the 20th to
Saturday the twenty-second I'm going to
be flying out to New Hampshire I will be
at the I think anything it's a sixth st.
Anselm conference sponsored by the
Institute for st. Anselm's studies and
hosted at st. Anselm College so that is
always a fun thing i'll be presenting a
paper on anthem and virtue ethics
there'll be a lot of people that i know
there that i want to reconnect with
there's a lot of people i don't know but
i'm looking forward to meeting there if
you're in that area and you want to hear
me talk you can pop in at st. Anselm
College I think the conference is
actually held in the library so you know
right right there in the middle of
things and you can see the scene in some
collection as well so then I'll be
flying back and on Sunday the 23rd at
two p.m. central time we are going to
have our Hagel party now why are we
having a Hagel party because Hegel's
phenomenology of spirit is divided into
a number of sections and we made our way
through most of the early stuff are more
than halfway through the work now and
the reason section was over 200
paragraphs long in an 800 paragraph work
and we're moving into another massive
section spirit so we want to take a
little time to celebrate and and you
know just catch up with each other so
I'll be actually be having three Hagel
events this this month counting the
public one and the Hagel party and the
Patrian exclusive Hagel session now the
Hagel party that's for everybody if you
if you like Hagel or you just want to
chat with me and raise a glass you're
welcome to do so Tuesday's the 25th at
12pm again central time we have our free
webinar on Aristotle on friendship and
relationships nikka McKay and ethics
book eight and nine we'll be talking
about such things as are there different
kinds of friendships or different sorts
of love that we might feel for each
other when should you cut somebody loose
is it okay to ever use somebody all
these sorts of interesting questions and
quantities that get posed thursday the
27th at 6pm here in Milwaukee at the
Shorewood public library we have our MKE
stoic fellowship so if you're in the
area and you want to talk about stoicism
particularly about epictetus and you
want to see some other people who are
you trying to use it to work out kinks
in their life show up and we'll be happy
to see you saturday the 29th at 10am and
4pm that's two different sessions we
will be having our intensive online
seminars each of these is two hours long
we'll be talking about
Aristotle friendship you know the
relationships all sorts of other things
so it's sort of like the webinar except
doing at much as they like to call it
these days deeper dive right and i'll be
giving some nice resources to the people
who come to that as well that's
everything that we've got going on as
far as events there is also the
aristotle course that i mentioned so i
should say a little bit about this i'm
not going to say too much because i'm
linking to a video below you can watch
which tells you about the course it's
actually two courses i split it up into
two in part because there's so much
material there's almost a hundred videos
there's you know dozens of lesson pages
handouts worksheets I've got quizzes set
up it's it's an intensive online
environment and it you work at it at
your own pace if you've ever wanted to
study the nikah mckay and ethics but you
were you know finding it difficult or or
you put it off you might want to
consider this course or if you you've
already looked at it and you want to go
further into detail that somebody who's
been studying it for about 20 years
actually a little bit longer than that
then you want to check out this course
so the link is below check it out you
can actually preview some of the content
for free and then you can see whether
you want to do it or not video work I'm
planning on doing a lot of video work
this month I promise to get to shooting
some stuff on SART last month i'm hoping
to get to it this month on the flies and
maybe a few other things in SART i'm
also going to be you know moving into
the spirit section with half hour Hagel
getting a lot more aristotle categories
videos done in part because i'm prepping
for a course on that i'll do some more
personal videos including some stuff
about my own philosophical development
and of course we'll have the event
videos coming up from the anne mccaffrey
and
I think probably also from the Anselm
conference as well the mayor's class is
continuing my students are now getting
to the point where they have to write
the longer papers I've got a lot of
tutorial students and you know a few
clients with philosophical counseling
and coaching by the way if you're
interested in those sort of services you
can go to the reason I a website check
them out and you can always email me at
Greg at reason IL if you're interested
in discussing those sorts of things I'll
be doing a lot of work doing curriculum
development for priority thinking on
doing some course building in our own
reason I owe Academy want to tell you
about the two courses that I'm very
ambitiously hoping to roll out later on
this month or at the beginning of next
month I do want to produce a course on
Aristotle's categories and that's a good
bit of work but it would be very
rewarding because i know i found that
text incredibly confusing when i was a
student and then i'm going to do another
short course on Cicero's stoic paradoxes
a lot of work this month as well for
stoicism today I'm going to be doing
more writing in blog stuff hopefully get
one out in partially examined life
hopefully get something done in policy
of truth my own blog or xst and oh IDK
who knows i might even get to write
something in heavy metal philosopher you
know fingers crossed got some other
writing projects underway as well still
working on the air saw the aristotle and
anger book the stoicism and anger books
that's that's a lot of work and i'm
working on a few other you know bits and
pieces of other writing projects
including the ants on paper on virtue
but I have some other papers that need
to be polished up and sent out so a busy
month ahead and I hope that you'll join
us for our online events certainly check
them out all the stuff is in the
descriptions below the video you can you
can click on those and find out a lot
more I don't need to go into any more
detail about that sort of
up and as the last thing we're starting
to fill up our calendar for fall 2017
I've already got some things booked in
in various places but if you're
interested in having me come out and
speak or provide a workshop or you know
lead a discussion or something like that
go ahead and email me Greg it reason I
oh and pitch me what you'd like me to
come in and talk about and we'll we'll
talk terms alright so I hope you have a
great month ahead and maybe I'll see you
in the ether or here face to face